y
yo bailé vuela de vuelta a eeuu tras su
gira por oriente medio en arabia saudita
aseguró que su país continuará
trabajando en labores de
contraterrorismo en la región así como
por la defensa de los derechos humanos y
por contrarrestar la influencia de rusia
china e irán
las fuerzas rusas continúan bombardeando
la región ucraniana de donges los
ataques dejaron al menos siete muertos y
en las últimas horas la ciudad del cni
pro fue impactada por más de 50 cohetes
según el gobernador regional ampliamos
desde ucrania
naciones unidas- pidió detener el
suministro de armas haití el organismo
informó que al menos 234 personas
murieron o resultaron heridas en medio
de disturbios entre el 8 y el 12 de
julio pasados los 15 países del consejo
de seguridad aprobaron mantener el
mandato de su oficina en el país
analizamos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 s rodrigo será no y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos con el
presidente joe biden que se despidió de
medio oriente después de la que ha sido
su primera visita a la región como
mandatario un polémico encuentro con el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman y
la falta de consenso para aumentar la
producción de petróleo marcaron esta
visita el mandatario se despidió
reafirmando su compromiso con la región
en un intento por frenar la influencia
de rusia y china- en la zona también con
el respeto a los derechos humanos
arabia saudita advirtió que habrá
consecuencias negativas si washington
intenta imponer sus valores natalia
plazas nos cuenta los detalles
job aiden deja medio oriente con las
manos vacías pero con palabras de
compromiso en la región en la que
pretende mantener su influencia y alejar
las de rusia y china unicom en cuestión
me está quedando claro cuán
estrechamente unidos están los intereses
estadounidenses con el éxito en medio
oriente
webó una web
y no nos vamos a ningún lado y no
dejaremos un vacío que puedan llenar
china rusia o irán
vamos a construir sobre este momento un
activo liderazgo estadounidense en su
último día de gira 'bye den se reunió
con los líderes de irak egipto y
emiratos árabes unidos- y participó en
una cumbre del consejo de cooperación
del golfo entre los principales temas
estuvieron la influencia de irán en la
región y las intenciones de washington
de integrar a israel como parte de un
nuevo eje para contrarrestar la
influencia de teherán una propuesta que
no gustó a riad no anses for zion su
force el sur con tres estados unidos
apoyará y fortalecerá las alianzas con
países que suscriben el orden
internacional y nos aseguraremos de que
estos países puedan defenderse de
ataques internacionales durante la gira
el tema que copó los titulares fue su
saludo con el príncipe heredero de
arabia saudita mohamed bin salman aquí
en la diplomacia estadounidense culpa
del asesinato del periodista llama al
hashtag y el encuentro generó críticas
pues contradecía las promesas de bailén
en su campaña electoral
aseguró que convertiría a riad en un
paria internacional hayden llegó a
arabia saudita con la esperanza de
alcanzar un acuerdo sobre la producción
de petróleo para ayudar a reducir los
precios de la gasolina que han llevado
la inflación en eeuu a máximos de 40
años por el momento no se consiguió un
acuerdo pero washington espera encontrar
apoyo de riad y otros gobiernos del
golfo en esta materia
entretanto israel atacó instalaciones
militares en gaza luego de que cuatro
cohetes fueran disparados desde la
franja a territorio israelí el ejército
de israel informó que se desplegaron
aviones de combate contra la instalación
perteneciente a la organización
islamista hamás que gobierna gaza desde
hace 15 años previamente los militares
israelíes denunciaron que dos cohetes
fueron lanzados desde la franja contra
el pueblo de ashkelón y otros dos contra
ajustan el intercambio de fuego se
produjo horas después de que el
presidente joe biden abandonara israel
tras tres días de visita oficial
las fuerzas rusas continúan bombardeando
la región ucraniana de donges los
ataques que dejaron al menos siete
muertos y una veintena de heridos se
produjeron en las localidades de back
but first of new york así a su vez dos
personas murieron cerca de mi pro ciudad
que fue impactada por más de 50 cohetes
según el gobernador regional en el lugar
se encuentra catalina gómez ángel
enviada especial de france 24 que
previamente nos daba más detalles
esta es la escena que se puede ver esta
mañana en la ciudad de de niro donde
anoche se dio ese gran ataque en la
parte es residencial de la ciudad las
autoridades hablan de seis misiles
cuatro de ellos interceptados cuyos
restos habrían caído en las diferentes
partes de esta ciudad la cuarta más
grande de ucrania la ciudad industrial y
bastante extensa que se ha convertido en
el pulmón para dar todo ese apoyo
logístico a la región del donbass cerca
de aquí dos de esos otros misiles
habrían caído en esta parte que está a
mis espaldas no tenemos autorización de
firmarlo esta mañana pero lo que sí se
sabe es que uno de sus misiles cayó en
el centro de la calle dejando un gran
cráter allí impacto en un automóvil que
pasaba que quedó totalmente calcinado
otros automóviles en la vida también
quedaron quemados y se habla de tres
personas fallecidas uno de ellos un
conductor de autobuses públicos que en
ese momento había terminado su trabajo y
otra edificación sumada a las
residencias que aquí sería una fábrica
de las cuales hay varias nosotros cuando
salíamos ayer del lugar vimos diferentes
explosiones como si estuviera explotando
pólvora como consecuencia del calor la
gente corrió volvió a buscar refugio en
sus casas o en el metro pero hoy amanece
todo más tranquilo se está a la espera
de que lleguen equipos de investigación
para saber realmente qué fue lo que pasó
en este lugar estos últimos ataques se
reportan después del bombardeo contra la
ciudad de binish ya en el centro de
ucrania en donde murieron unas 23
personas entre ellas cuatro menores el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
pidió que se reconozca a rusia como
estado terrorista marina sardiña tienen
los detalles
otro hospital ucraniano reducido a
escombros por los misiles rusos lo que
constituye un crimen de guerra los
habitantes de venecia siguen
conmocionados tras los múltiples
bombardeos de las fuerzas del kremlin
sobre las posiciones civiles
no puedo creer que haya sobrevivido el
tranvía me salvó cuando hubo una
explosión yo estaba en esa plaza oí un
ruido y vi un punto lo único que pude
hacer fue cruzar la calle luchar a semis
y posee los equipos de rescate continúan
buscando supervivientes decenas de
personas resultaron heridas y al menos
23 han muerto incluyendo cuatro menores
entre los fallecidos lista una niña de
tan solo cuatro años con síndrome de
dawn
la tía de la menor habló de su dolor
tomás no entiendo por qué hay tanto odio
hacia nosotros no hemos hecho nada a
nadie nunca atacamos vivimos
pacíficamente y trabajamos los
ucranianos somos gente muy trabajadora
nos gusta trabajar nunca amenazamos a
nadie entonces porque rusia nos ha hecho
esto simplemente no puedo explicarlo
por su parte el presidente de volodymyr
selenski pidió reconocer a rusia como un
estado terrorista y reiteró su promesa
de llevar ante la justicia a todos los
responsables del mortífero ataque gris
tras la ventada en venecia y otros
ataques terroristas del ejército ruso
los ocupantes deben sentir lo que
significa una respuesta justa al terror
en particular se sentirá gracias a las
sanciones
algunos vecinos realizaron el viernes un
altar improvisado a las víctimas
mientras que rusia asegura que el ataque
iba dirigido a un edificio donde las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas se reunían
con proveedores de armas de extranjeros
quien niega por su parte esta versión
volvemos la mirada de ti porque naciones
unidas pidió detener el suministro de
armas a el país en medio del aumento de
la violencia entre pandillas el
organismo informó que al menos 234
personas murieron o resultaron heridas
en medio de disturbios entre el 8 y el
12 de julio pasados los 15 países del
consejo de seguridad también aprobaron
por unanimidad una para mantener el
mandato de su oficina en el país como
órgano para apoyar a las instituciones
haitianas para analizar la situación en
haití hablamos con milo milford analista
y periodista haitiano milo bienvenido a
france 24 las cifras que ha dado a
conocer la onu suponen un aumento
respecto a periodos anteriores o son
parte de un problema continuado
y
esto el modelado de una gaita que
existen desde más de 20 años y la
diferencia que hay entre
el año 2000 y ahora es que en los años
2000 había una había un poco grupos
armados en el país y se tratan de los
grupos armados que definían al partido
lavalas por ejemplo es ahora es que se
trata de
un proceso de gran sensación del país si
está ahora existen más de 200 grupos
armados en el país y estos grupos de
varones se encuentran en todo el partido
del país en todo el país es por eso que
vemos el canal días más años
y varias y llenas de igualdad sin ley en
todo el territorio
también hay que hablar de la
inexistencia de las autoridades que
hacen que estas bandas armadas tienen
mucho más poder para para hacerlo geely
y precisamente de esto último le quería
hablar porque dada la crisis económica
política y social del país es posible
una solución a corto o medio plazo al
problema de la violencia y de estas
bandas armadas
una una solución a esta crisis no es
fácil yo creo que para encontrar una
solución muy práctica
debemos pasar por una revolución una
solamente una agregación puede hacerlos
en una resolución
muy efectiva muy positiva en este país
porque yo yo digo yo digo eso es que
siempre hay elecciones en el país y
hasta hablar las elecciones no no no
y resulta que eso quiere decir una una
función pasa con la la el fútbol pasa
por la calle pasa por la de una
revolución total para cambiar todo todo
todo esto la estructura económica
política y social del país sí señor
milford muchas gracias por atendernos en
france 24 y estaremos muy atentos a lo
que siga pasando en haití
cambiamos de tema porque en sri lanka se
leyó en la sesión de hoy del parlamento
la carta de renuncia del presidente de
gotabaya rajapaksa quien ha prometido no
desvincularse de la política de su país
uno de sus principales aliados raniel be
creme singer es el principal favorito
para sucederle una vez que se realice la
próxima semana la elección en el
parlamento esa perspectiva alienta sin
embargo el disgusto de los que se han
manifestado en sri lanka más en el
siguiente informe
defendiendo su gestión ante el
parlamento en una carta enviada desde su
exilio en singapur el depuesto
presidente de sri lanka gotabaya
rajapaksa dijo que había hecho todo lo
posible por su país culpó a los
confinamientos por el commit 19 del
empeoramiento de la crisis económica y
se declaró orgulloso de haber protegido
a su país de lo peor de la pandemia
lleva la vida de la ncaa vetaba que es
motivo de satisfacción personal para mí
haber sido capaz de proteger a nuestro
pueblo de la pandemia a pesar de la
crisis económica que ya estábamos
enfrentando además saltó te atacaron
aquí estaba me da igual quiero enfatizar
que siempre he dado lo mejor por mi
madre patria he contribuido al máximo
con el país y continuaré haciéndolo en
el futuro
su nota no detalla cómo se vinculará con
la política en el futuro de ese el
exilio después de la renuncia oficial de
rajapaksa el jueves el parlamento de sri
lanka debe comenzar ahora el proceso de
elegir un nuevo presidente en una sesión
prevista para el 20 de julio a su vez el
viernes su primer ministro ranil biker
messinger tomó juramento como presidente
interino tiene el respaldo del partido
de gobierno y es considerado favorito
para prevalecer en una elección la
próxima semana si lo hace los largos
meses de protesta en sri lanka aparecen
lejos de terminar ganamos la batalla de
mandar a casa a gotabaya rajapaksa
ganaremos la batalla final de hacer lo
mismo con ramil y créeme sin guía y
también ganaremos la guerra en su
totalidad necesito un nuevo presidente
un tipo con un buen conocimiento
económico eso es lo que necesitamos
los manifestantes culpan a raya pacsa y
su poderosa familia junto a sus aliados
incluyendo mi crema single de la grave
escasez de comida y combustible y de una
inflación sin precedentes que el mes
pasado alcanzó un récord de 54 6%
vamos a finalizar ahora en parís en la
capital de francia donde inició la
tercera edición del festival de cine al
aire libre el conocido como cinema
paradiso ocupando el icónico patrio
curca gay del museo del louvre durante
cuatro noches de magia cinematográfica
se espera ahora que cada noche acudan
unos 2500 espectadores para ver una
selección de documentales y de películas
de ficción el patio en el que se
desarrolla el festival fue acondicionado
con una pantalla de 24 x 11 metros
también con instalaciones de comida y
con una cabina de dj para actuaciones de
música en directo
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan conectados a
france24 y recuerden que pueden ampliar
toda esta hay mucha más información en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]